in this video i'm going to be giving my
predictions and talking about what i
believe is going to happen in 2022 in
the property market
[Music]
our house prices gonna crash in 2022.
my name's samuel leeds i've been
investing in property now for 13 years i
saw the recession that we had in 2008
i've seen the recession that we've had
with the pandemic and although we've
been in a recession throughout the
pandemic house prices have been
absolutely booming the average house in
the united kingdom stands today
according to halifax at 276
000 pounds house prices have been rising
faster than we've seen in over a decade
and many many people including massive
media outlets and newspapers are saying
that house prices in the uk are about to
fall they're going to plummet and
they're going to crash and they're going
to crash hard i don't believe that's
going to happen and in this video i'm
going to be giving my predictions and
talking about what i believe is going to
happen in 2022 in the property market if
you just type in google house prices
you're going to see all this talk of a
crash you can see look
national wide amid fears of housing
market crash birmingham live will the uk
housing market crash in 2022 bubble to
burst after really striking new data
sounds alarming
sky house prices could come crashing
down so the the whole media the
narrative is that this year we're now in
january is going to be year of property
prices plummeting and crashing let me
tell you why i absolutely do not think
that that's going to happen in the uk in
2022.
for a start
google news okay everyone gets their
information from google but what are
google actually doing
did you know that google have just
invested
billions of pounds in london in the uk
for their new offices
would google really be spending billions
of pounds investing in property in
london uk if they thought the property
market was going to crash probably not
did you know that there are lenders
mortgage providers that are giving loans
up to 40 years this is brand new
information by the way habito mortgages
have just announced
that you can put down a 10
deposit on a house they'll give 90
percent
and then they will guarantee a fixed
rate just over 5 which isn't that
expensive
5
for 40 years do you really think these
big banks and lenders would be happy to
bet on the property market not crashing
by guaranteeing a fixed rate for four
decades if they really thought the
housing market was about to crash i
think probably not and some people might
argue yeah but samuel habito who are
they they're just a small lender but
here's what you want to do you want to
look at what the bank of england are
doing the bank of england are the
central bank in the uk that set the
trend for most other lenders the bank of
england have scrapped some of the
restrictions and are making it easier to
get mortgages they're helping first-time
buyers with the help to buy
government-backed schemes there are more
lenders offering 95
mortgages in fact habito themselves are
planning in the summer to give out 95
mortgages as well and as they do this
what's going to happen is more
first-time buyers are going to be able
to get on the property ladder which is
going to continue to push up the prices
of properties in the uk so yes we've had
a massive boom is the boom gonna
continue at the rate i'm sure it's gonna
slow down but are we gonna see a massive
crash in 2022
i'm saying no let me know your thoughts
in the comments i'd love to know your
opinions and i'll be doing regular
updates about the property market here
at this youtube channel
[Music]